c'est la version moderne de la mère
Michel partie sans réclamer ses chats à
poster sur 6 une vingtaine de félins ont
été retrouvés à abandonnés dans un
appartement la propriétaire introuvable
c'est une association qui a dû les
recueillir en attendant mieux faustineau
la fenêtre de la cuisine c'est celle-ci
elle était ouverte et la fenêtre de la
chambre à côté était également ouverte
c'est dans cet immeuble de poser sur 6
ont été retrouvés plus d'une vingtaine
de chats dont certains morts enfermés
pendant trois semaines dans un
appartement insalubre qui avait quitté
fin juin leur propriétaire en les
abandonnant sur place ce n'est que grâce
à la solidarité de huit voisins que ces
chats ont pu être maintenus en vie il y
avait une odeur il y a une odeur les
bruits aussi qu'on entendait les chats
se battre et puis on les voyait au bord
des fenêtres du coup naturellement ça
c'est fait avec les voisins on a décidé
de nourrir on leur donnait à manger que
par l'extérieur c'est à dire que le
monsieur est monté à l'échelle et puis
balancer des croquettes sur le sol elle
pouvait pas rentrer à l'intérieur
s'arrêter une violation du domicile
l'intervention des gendarmes le 20
juillet a finalement soulagé tout le
quartier une quinzaine de chats rescapés
ont été prises en charge par
l'association Le Chat provincial à
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps
trop faut pas abuser
un refuge pourtant déjà plein à craquer
avec environ 450 chats recueillis par an
dans le but de leur trouver une nouvelle
famille d'adoption ces trois-là font
partie du groupe de possés ils sont 15
en tout ils sont obligés d'être en boxe
tout de suite là pour le moment il y
avait pas mal de puces sur place ne
serait-ce que ça
ils sont ils étaient bourrés de verre
aussi donc tout de suite la pipette
magique et puis tant qu'ils ont pas eu
le rappel de vaccin on sépare et donc là
tout le monde maintenant est passé chez
le vétérinaire qu'on a réussi à trouver
des solutions pour qu'il soit quand même
avec un confort maximal
malgré la situation estivale parce que
les les places sont difficiles à trouver
en ce moment les chats de possédés
peuvent être adoptés dès maintenant pour
cela il faut contacter le refuge pour
l'instant cette personne ce sont déjà
manifestées